do we have a look an intro like it
doo-doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo Shh
some like that look at graphics on it
it's an inside insider don't look too
annoyed these are all terrible ideas I'm
Joe Vella with insider and today we are
doing kind of a video am a podcast
videocast with my two best friend /
co-workers Caroline a John Ian a good
onion agajanian and Sydney Kramer yeah
kind of throw out some questions sort of
like an AMA what people really want to
know about the job about us put them on
Instagram and I went through them and
we're gonna kind of hit some of the most
asked questions today a lot of questions
that we got was something that a extent
of like our day to day or how we end up
picking stories so guess like in general
how would you explain to someone how you
end up making a video like pitching it
and it getting actually produced it
whatever I just like search like
Instagram is a big tool to like help me
find like cool places people like places
that people want to go and see oh hello
joining us today
yeah was there Paul yeah there you go
I feel like he felt ignored he never he
never jumped up on the table like I
think there's some questions for Paul
yeah makes me want to stop
yeah it's harder because also like it's
not just the visuals of it it's that
like story behind it you know yeah like
we want to want to see the people behind
it and like a lot of even on Instagram
though you find like a lot of like
gimmicky things that like people just
made you know to go viral or to go on
Instagram and like to get it that quick
attention but like I don't know those
stuff like fade and it's not if there's
not like big meat behind it you
yes like I know you go but like if they
created that big meet because they had a
family of 15 that they wanted to serve
and I was like easy
that's like fun you know I want to know
about your family you know but like if
you just like put a bunch of patties -
mm-hmm Caroline wants to know about your
family yeah all about them
DM Caroline and tell her all about your
family I like to meet everyone how cool
would it be to me a lot of people's
families like that I really thought I
don't know about mine that's enough I
find meeting new people exhausting well
every day two siblings next question but
also like even just like going out and
walking around you can like find a shop
or a restaurant and you think that's
cool and then you like digging a little
deeper and yeah you find story
we all went to go do like Hollywood
makeup schools and like it's not school
was really fun and you like
special-effects transformations are
really fun so it's nice we get to learn
if you see us filming at a restaurant
come off to us and be like hey like I
want to take a bite on camera like we
love to get you know those pic of a
second but like if I'm shooting
something I'm talking don't like get
right in my face I mean like you know
take pickup moments yeah but like I feel
like I always like whenever a mother
also will come up to you like like hey
is this for insider can I be in the
things like bro it's too nice yeah I
keep making this mistake I feel like
you've yelled on me a few times about
this is that I'll go to shoots really
hungry every time I'm like oh yeah we're
doing that talk with thing a - I'll just
skip lunch and know what time to get
them just like chow
Jesse he's eating anymore
but your interest eat more tacos Oh God
and then listen me I'm eating them and
like shoving them in my mouth like if
let's slow down bodega shots like so I
probably should grab a snack before I go
yeah especially because I feel like at
this point you know there's no want for
good food so the idea that I'm gonna
skip lunch and then just like go
hog-wild like that on a shoe just is not
appealing at all I'd rather like eat
food be like satiated and like feel okay
while I'm working and I'm like oh let me
try it a taco favorite part of the job
you go first uh meeting different people
every day definitely seeing how we can
change a business you know especially
smaller businesses or food trucks or you
know food stands and places that are
kind of you know trying to make ends
meet and then having a video come out
and having their business blow up and
link do really well and you know sell
out of food and need to hire more people
and seeing the eyes like I think that
definitely the best part yeah we got
that email from the guys from the garlic
restaurant the sting they said they're
doing really well cuz of that video
business is up like 10% no shot at this
stinking rose I like the place of food
is really good for forever
yeah I don't know being a camera see my
face getting the 60 million views to
watch me eat fast food video I like
producing videos I like making stuff
kind of we're doing this like my wardens
the word I want to use but really just
like I mean if it people can't tell him
a lot older than the both of you and I
had like a you're not that much older
than me or am i fuller than previous ten
years of working like any terrible like
entry-level job not really there's
anything for this and just like waking
up every day and just being like like 6
a.m. just being like this is gonna suck
for like years so in fact I get to wake
up like I get to go to a cool place meet
interesting people shoot something and
the people are gonna see it like all
those
things like that is awesome yeah I mean
I was a research assistant hedge funds
and mutual funds for like five or six
years so this is definitely much better
than that this is your first job right
my first real job and I've had a lot of
internships uh Sydney you're the food
King yeah of Instagram by the way check
around in crepes of wrath Instagram
we've gotten eat a lot of like really
good stuff you know but every once in a
while there's something that's kind of
like a little rough he's giving anything
reason I can think of something that we
ate almost killed us but do you think
anything that's like and of course you
know we're having fun here but anything
it's so crazy so big so decadent some
that's just like oh man yeah I mean the
food fair stuff's been pretty rough like
I'm not gonna lie you know we were in
the Midwest oh wow we went to one place
I don't think that we're ever gonna
actually do the video upon reviewing the
footage the kitchen I mean I'm not gonna
name the name of the restaurant sure the
kitchen was quote gross and like the
food was gross it was so bad in fact
that when we were shooting we just shot
people that were already eating there
because I just couldn't bring myself to
like eat the food after like being in
the kitchen and seeing like how things
were handled sure it was just dirty but
I mean I will say for the most part like
the food that we go to shoot tastes good
and is good because we're not gonna
shoot something that looks disgusting of
course um but this place looked like it
might be a fun story and it was not fun
Mauritius but I think Caroline has more
stories I like and I think you do too
we're both adventurous eaters yeah we
like like different food Karen I think
has tried a lot of new food I definitely
I mean I mean the first thing that comes
to mind is any of our spicy food shoots
I was like I don't know what we don't
even like think those reactions because
I feel like Joe and I have done a few of
them like a bunch of people on the team
like especially okay so Joe and I did a
spicy ramen challenge and we I was like
it was a cold day I was like yeah wrong
one's gonna be good and Joe was hungry
and so like we're gonna really go in
like a genius I didn't eat that day we
got
no food in your stomach eating the
spiciest ramen in Los Angeles and like
coffee is my blood so I have no stomach
lining anyway I've been drinking coffee
non-stop since I was like 12 so ready
like my stomach is just can't handle
anything
so that's spicy ramen shoot we went and
we were like really going in and like
Joe especially was like determined to
finish that challenge we oh my gosh
you're practically John you got this
you're like halfway there I'm so to
shake anything for my fans
that was a bad idea we wanted the video
to be like we tried the spicy chip first
of all we didn't come close no didn't
come close you came really close
actually yeah like Joe ate all the
noodles but he didn't like you have to
drink the broth yeah I was just like
pretty much like I couldn't well I just
moved here like I'd only been here for
like a couple weeks and I moved here
from New York and my stuff hadn't
arrived yet and also my wife was out of
town so she she was traveling for work
and none of my stuff so I basically
imagined an apartment with nothing in it
except like the pile of clothes I'm
sleeping on right so also I have an
empty medicine cabinet so I get home and
what oh my stomach's killing me then act
like I like crawl to Albertson and I
buyed like bought like a ton of Tom's
you know zantac something that you drink
and just smoke was it in a Friday spent
the whole weekend just like laying on my
bare a hardwood floor like this like
like just waves of pain hitting me
anything for insider baby company man
what's up I don't do spicy food
challenges I have self-respect that is
good but it is really fun like I am
always even after that I think I did
like two or three more spicy food stuff
and I was like I know it's gonna hurt
but I'm it's fine it's fun it's the
driving that you have to do after cuz
you're like stuck in LA traffic and your
stomach is like
what's the thing what's the thing you
hold them right here I'm kind of holding
it up and flex I'm not suspended in the
drycleaner handle yeah holding up this
like cuz because the the bumping of the
car is just too much I'm like like using
my core to not like the key mice look
fun video though hit you with some quick
ones real quick and we think it's a
toughest part of this job me I know it
as pitches hardest I'm finding things
for me it's like a constant stress of
like pitching that's for me I guess most
stressful part is like if I really
really am interested in doing a video on
some place and I have to like take a lot
of convincing like people are very
skeptical it's like it's gonna be great
but they find out that it's great like
after the video goes up after we show up
and it's great so I guess like the
convincing the skeptics that it's a good
thing you know okay I would say just
like time management honestly because
there's so many things to shoot and
there's so many videos we're working on
and I think I'm constantly just like
juggling like script writing and
producing and like shooting and editing
and I could never like quite get that
balance even though I try to I have not
traveled outside of the country for this
job but both of you have my was exciting
she was swimming hole safari in Jamaica
Fort Antonia when I jumped into the
rabbit hole
scary a shoot and probably the funnest
cool
Tokio obviously don't give the best when
I was gonna be I Tokyo and what are they
sending you and I there to start dude I
mean I'm there the first time I went to
Tokyo years ago the first thing I did
was like look up like apartment yeah my
wife and I went there for our honeymoon
and since then we're like it's just
understood that we will eventually live
there yeah at some point we will just
migrated over to Tokyo I've never been
terming yeah I really want to go so
hopefully I get to plan a trip with my
family and but if it's her family or
with work like I'm definitely down to
shoot videos so Armenia I'm coming soon
one day and he cut you haven't gone yet
for work do you want to go I mean I for
work I don't know like I'll be honestly
I like traveling for work but I'd rather
travel for leisure yeah I want to talk
about personal if you got to go if you
got to pick a place you got to go to for
a couple weeks to shoot videos yeah I
get up with the logistics of it just
like
probably like Hong Kong I think we've
talked about Hong Kong Hong Kong's
like I haven't I've never been it seems
awesome lots of really cool food but
also I've been to Shanghai but I think
Shanghai would be a cool place to go for
for work as well yeah I love traveling
for work so wherever and I'm down also
whenever we travel for work like we're
doing things that we would maybe as
tourists like we're filming things like
in food places and travel stuff that
we'd want to do when we're there so I
feel like I'm enjoying my time work I
love you I feel like guilty like not
having your wife there with you like I
feel guilty like if I'm like ask me but
you're the two of us she's thrilled I'm
waiting for no I feel guilty they found
like going somewhere cool and I don't
get to share it with creamer like I want
him to be there it's awesome I feel good
sharing it with your co-workers no no
all right that's been the first episode
of whatever this show is called you guys
have any questions we didn't get it by
the way like you guys asked questions on
Instagram both their personal accounts
and our you to our insider ones I don't
know roughly 10,000 questions we'll
probably do this again later with other
questions maybe talk more about videos I
don't know what do you guys want to know
if you couldn't let us know in the
comments that'd be great
and thanks for watching goodbye what eat
fast food like in your free time as well
are these like yeah Joe loves Arby's
yeah it's great I never won an Arby's
fan right there Arby's what did you hear
this they've just been talking trash
about Arby's and everyone had it